i feel like i'm the inspector gadget of
coffee espresso gadget
espresso
hey guys it's alex and i love coffee
which is a good thing because today i'm
gonna be making tons of coffee with
gadgets i found on the internet gadgets
and coffee my two favorite things i'll
be evaluating them on price how well
they work and if you should consider
getting them we've got a lot of gadgets
to get to so let's check them out all
right here we are we've got a lot of
gadgets to kick things off we've got
this mini presso a miniature espresso
maker we've also got two milk frothers
this one's kind of pricey and this one
is cheap so we'll see how they both do
we've got these two things for latte art
if you follow me on ig you know i love a
latte art we also have this coffee bean
roaster we'll see how that goes we have
our two grinders manual and electric
we've got the big boy over here a vacuum
coffee maker all right let's put these
gadgets to work
okay first up we have our on the go
espresso maker
comes with a little bag it's it's not
too big which is obviously good
especially if you're camping it's like a
russian doll you just keep going oh
okay so i have my little filter basket
with my coffee grounds
this i fill with boiling water this is
the water tank gonna screw that on the
bottom and now i'm going to unlock this
it says start pumping slowly above the
cup oh let's try it this way
it's going
it sounds like a dying bird all right so
we've got our beautiful cup of espresso
you got the little like foamy foam on
top let's see how it tastes
i think this is really good i would be
stoked to have this this is some
glamping stuff all right next let's test
out our milk frothers
so first up we have this one by morocco
[Music]
definitely looks pretty legit i'm gonna
go for the heat and froth which is
pressing it once okay so i'm gonna pour
in my milk i've got some half and half
here
and i'm just gonna press this little
button oh it's already going pretty easy
i like things that are easy it's already
foaming that's fast oh there it goes
wow
oh
so i'm going to pour it in our cup a
whoo
look at that
[Music]
it's perfect i love it next thing we're
doing is this milk boss milk frother wow
i've never had one that comes with like
a stand that's kind of cool so this
thing didn't come with batteries which
i never have batteries so if i bought
this i'd be like a little annoyed let's
try
oh
[Music]
i feel like a barista there's some sort
of like technique of being kind of
closer to the top of the milk to get the
air incorporated for the foam
foaminess
i think we're good should i pour it in
yeah that that looks cool although i
would say it's like a way bubblier foam
this one's a nicer texture
you don't get that nice foamy like lip i
want the foam mustache
okay that's it for our milk frothers
next we're moving on to latte arts
we have two tools for making one of my
favorite pastimes latte art i've only
seen this one online it's a spice pen so
you put like spices in it and then you
can draw with it and this is like what i
use a toothpick for for like for the
finer details of the latte art okay
let's get it going so i guess i'm gonna
open this guy up first the spice pen it
works i just need to fill it with my
spices so right now i have some cocoa
powder you could also use like cinnamon
nutmeg
matcha oh my god i didn't even notice
that it's i swear it's like a beluga
whale that's hilarious it has eyes and
everything i think it's pretty
straightforward i'm gonna spoon this in
here
it's like a little messy to do so he's
gonna press it and it i think it just
vibrates and then it like spits it out
okay i'm gonna do a flower
no
what i'm worried that the cocoa powder
might be too chunky yeah it looks like
it's clogging in there unfortunately so
i i think cocoa powder is a no now i'm
going to use cinnamon which is already a
little bit finer than the clumpier uh
cocoa powder and i'm also going to sift
it so this already is kind of like a lot
of work so give a little test
[Music]
oh much better much better
[Music]
it just gets like clogged so easily
this is not very good
[Music]
yeah this sucks i'm very disappointed i
feel duped
and now and now it's not even turning on
anymore okay our beluga whale is in
timeout now we are moving on to this
metal toothpick thing
i already like this butter like i used a
toothpick once to like make a cat and
that's what i'm trying to do it's
probably multi-purpose like you could
use this for your latte art and then
also use it to like pop a pimple
i'm pretty happy with my cat this is
cappuccino
[Music]
so next we have something that looks
pretty interesting it is a eco ceramic
hand roaster so this is for roasting
your own coffee beans which is actually
something i've never done before this is
bigger than i thought it would be i
think
it would be straightforward put the
beans in there and heat it up so we have
our unroasted beans here i guess i'm
just gonna put a couple of spoonfuls in
here
[Music]
what we're looking for is for the beans
to change color get darker and to expand
[Music]
it's like popcorn all right definitely a
lot of popping going on um i think it
might come out through the handle
oh that's kind of cool okay that was
nice i appreciated that so we've got our
fresh roasted beans here and now let's
test some grinders
okay sweet so we have a manual and an
electric coffee grinder compact design
fits easily in handbags i'm gonna put
some of these beans in here let's try
this
put this on top
hand crank goes on
look at that there we go
the thought of doing this every morning
is insane to me
okay let's try the other one for the
next one we're gonna try our
chardo
okay
so i'm gonna pour our beans in here
[Music]
it's already to the coarsest level of
that so much easier this definitely
feels closer to what you'd get out of a
bag we've got our coffee grounds and now
it's time to put them to use with the
big daddy bodum vacuum coffee maker
in here we've got our
our pot
literally
what the heck this is so interesting we
also got a novel of instructions
so i'm gonna put two cups of water in
here
[Music]
and then i'm gonna do two scoops of our
fresh ground
coffee oop oh just gotta turn on
bubbles
this is really sciency this is kind of
cool i i like this
it's interactive
what is happening so we got a lot of
noises coming through
okay i messed up i was supposed to put
the water in here and
i put it in here so we're gonna try this
again we are going to fill our water in
here this time
two cups
and now
put this guy on here
coffee goes in here what we're actually
doing here which makes a lot more sense
than what i did before
this hot plate is gonna heat up our
water at the bottom gonna create some
water vapor which then goes up into the
top
saturating our grounds here and then
dripping back down into the bottom where
we have our pot of coffee the more you
know i'm like bill nye alex nye
the science girl
cool we're back in action
oh oh here we go yeah there we go so
when it turns off then it releases some
of that pressure and now the coffee is
going
it's a show this is a spectacle let's
see do i take this off of here
i know that seems kind of weird like
what do you do with that now this could
be really annoying to clean got my make
it fancy mug make it fancy this is
definitely a make it fancy coffee i'd
say
i should be careful
i'm going to try this is also our fresh
roasted coffee bean so i'm kind of
curious
[Music]
it's a nice clean basic morning cup of
joe all right next up my final verdicts
all right here are my thoughts bringing
it back to the mini preso this was fifty
dollars i actually really liked this i
think it's really useful if you are on
the go if you're camping and don't have
access to a full-blown espresso maker i
give this two thumbs up i really like
this frother i think it gave a really
nice luxurious foam it also heats up
your milk which is really helpful if
you're making a cappuccino or a latte
this is forty dollars and i would
absolutely consider getting this next we
have the zula milk frother this one
works well although it doesn't have the
capability to heat up any milk this
one's 12 so it's a little more
affordable although i would only
recommend this one if you want to like
mix things into your coffee rather than
making your phone next up we have our
latte art tools this was ten dollars and
although i appreciate that it's cute i
give it two thumbs down we paid 569 for
this metal latte art tool
it worked i would just say use a
toothpick so
middle next we have our coffee roaster
we paid
jesus we paid 30 for this one
and it it roasted our coffee but didn't
give the most even roast so i'm
probably gonna give this a thumbs down
next we have our coffee grinders
starting with the java press manual
coffee grinder this was
dollars and it did work although i just
feel like that's too much work for
grinding your coffee beans might as well
not do this
thumbs down
now we have our electronic coffee
grinder we paid thirty 33 for this one
and i loved it it was easy to use it's
functional it's quick and i give this
two thumbs up next we have our bodum
vacuum coffee maker we paid 54. for this
and i actually really enjoyed this i
think it's fun to get to watch the whole
process of the coffee making it's like a
science project it was fairly fast and
it produced a solid cup of coffee i give
this two thumbs up if you want to check
any of these out the links to the
products are below and let me know what
you want me to review next
i like so hyped up on coffee now
oh hands test
[Music]
oh
you